[Music]
our goal today
is to continue to expose and
continue to discuss the timeshare
industry
the american association of whatever
having to do with the timeshare business
is called
arda and they funded a report
that says that 87 percent of time share
owners rate their timeshare ownership
as good or excellent funded by the
timeshare industry
uh however university of central florida
did a study that says just the opposite
85 percent of time share owners who go
to contract
regret their purchase how many
businesses do
85 of their customers think they suck
and they stay open how many
unbelievable all right we're talking
with an attorney in missouri scott
montgomery who was uh
on behalf of elderly people ripped off
in the ozarks with timeshares had sued
several companies their answer was to
sue him
to sue the attorney and since they're a
small law firm to go ahead and just
bury them in discovery requests
buckets and failings of discovery
requests
to see if they can put these attorneys
out of business their goal
is to put these attorneys that sue them
out of business by
countersuing them or suing them and
burying
them scott that's what you said right
absolutely dave that's what's happening
now christian wall was on here a few
weeks ago another attorney who's
representing
attorneys who have been sued and is he
representing you too
yes he is dave oh good good sharp very
good
so you guys are kind of banding together
to fight back
we are absolutely uh we're trying to
uh gather together good uh litigators
from around the country to
combat this problem and you know our
firm we
we represent almost 7 000 time share
owners from around
the country and i would say that 100
of my thousands of clients think that
the timeshare
industry sucks and they hate their
timeshare and
regret their purchase tremendously yeah
so that's an unofficial survey right
there
but fairly accurate yeah if you if you
hire an attorney to sue somebody you
pretty much think they suck i think that
that's 100
yeah i go with that
that's fun so the cause of action from a
legal perspective that you guys usually
take if you're going to sue someone you
can't just make up something to sue them
about unless you're the timeshare
business which they
made up something to sue you about but
you guys are finding
actual fraudulent processes that you're
putting in the case i assume
absolutely dave we we sue for fraud
and for negligent misrepresentation and
for
violations of state merchandising
practices
act which allows our clients to
recover their damages along with their
attorney's fees
but we've also started filing lawsuits
based upon some more innovative causes
of action
uh i i think uh one is for
the charging of illegal document
preparation
fees if you if you go to a closing at
your timeshare sales presentation
you're probably going to be stuck with
hundreds or thousands of dollars of
illegal document preparation fees that
uh
that constitutes the unauthorized
practice of law that
that's a crime a non-attorney cannot
charge
for document preparation fees we're also
seeing
the tactics where the timeshare pushing
companies
they charge their uh they charge the
consumer
for title insurance title insurance for
these points you don't get title right
create it
if you don't get a title how can you get
title insurance
it is certainly a mystery to me but they
charge hundreds or thousands of dollars
for title insurance for points that they
created
it's just crazy we we have seen a large
time share pusher
charge uh thousands of dollars for a
life insurance policy
so the the consumer can you know be sure
and pay off their
debt to the timeshare company when uh
when they pass away we've also filed
suit
for the unauthorized practice of realty
you know these time shares there and
they're an interest in
real estate and the seller the agent
that have a real estate license
yeah the guy who's sitting across the
table from you it's a timeshare sales
presentation
they should have a realtor's license and
they don't
so we're filing suits on on the basis of
all of those things yeah and how often
are you getting them out these days
well that's a that's a great question it
depends on the
individual circumstances of the
individual case
yeah there are hundreds of time share
pushers in the country
but you got you said you had 7 000 cases
underway right
we have almost 7 000 clients currently
or who we have helped to obtain a
release
oh i've asked okay we've helped
thousands of people
obtain a release it is unfortunately it
is uh
much easier for you to get out of your
timeshare contract
if you are what is known in the industry
as paid in full
if you paid off your timeshare mortgage
and that's a thing
most timeshare purchases are financed if
you paid off your mortgage
and you've paid your annual maintenance
fees which are often
fifteen hundred dollars for something
you can't use if you're paid in full
we can often negotiate a uh release
for you from the timeshare pushing
company
yeah if you still have if you still have
a mortgage it's much more difficult
they don't want to give up that money
they've already but if they already got
your money they're more likely to let
you go
yeah that makes sense oh my gosh hey
scott we appreciate you sharing with us
today man
that's incredible i'm so sorry they're
going after you personally that's just
ridiculous but it's uh
it's par for the course with these guys
they think they have enough money to
just
bury anybody who takes them on and uh
you know now they've met somebody that's
not gonna happen